okay
for people joining this live stream uh
this is an incremental language
development meeting
and we are looking at functions that are
in the wolfram function repository
that we want to consider versions of as
part of
as part of our main system all right
so let's keep going boy why is this in
this
weird code font whatever
oh yeah unfortunately
okay whatever happened to the function
directory block which i was keen on
i i think we have a ticket for it
okay because
when the other function that i think
maybe is a better version is with
directory
or something i mean in other words
it's like temporarily set this as the
directory
so i'm saying yeah
i think it's a set directory that at the
end recovers the original
exactly
um
boy where should i put this uh
should we start a section about function
repository
that's a good idea we've saved similar
things in
just the general ild folder
and then there's also miscellaneous but
that's kind of a cop-out no
okay i mean
alternatively directory block which i
think was the same idea
yeah i think so
okay file queue
why isn't that file exists queue i
thought we already have something like
that
what's the difference between file queue
and file exists queue
i honestly don't remember other than
there is a difference
this is probably a rick hennigan
it's not it's a it's a tele production
oh
if path exists and is an ordinary file
maybe this is a duplicate
okay um check that out q does not check
if it's an ordinary file right
stay again you sound like you're in a
cave by the way
so the difference with file exists queue
is that it doesn't test if the file is
an ordinary file
as opposed to a directory
for example
maybe file exists you should have a
second argument that says that
well that's one way to present this
is seems like the right thing to do
because i can imagine several different
choices for um
you know what you want
that's what i think we should do
all right ensure file paths
boy
we don't have a mechanism for that
it seems there is this option create
intermediate directories
so perhaps it's a matter of propagating
that option
right i don't quite understand the point
of this i think this needs more study
well
the the note um what the note means is
that we're not necessarily recommending
it
as a standalone function but that the
functionality might be incorporated into
export
well that i think is worthwhile
that makes sense to me i grew that
okay
this one again i don't really know but
we should determine that
yeah we weren't sure if this was covered
already
well for director's size would be
directory bite count if it was anything
yes and that's not obviously wrong
that's not obviously a bad idea
because no
you know i think that would be actually
quite useful and a recursive directory
bike count would be even more useful
well allow people to say minus r
we have an internal version of this
function i think it should be
the implementation by the way jose might
well be that internal
version i see
count it doesn't make sense to allow
that to be recursive to give it an
option to allow it to be recursive
makes more sense to just say because the
the file byte count of a directory
is just the directory itself right
probably
i would expect 1k typically
right okay i think directory byte count
is a sensible thing to have
oh boy
yeah well that's a good idea but i don't
i'm not sure we have the right do we
have the right people here to discuss
that in detail
no no it's a suggestion to
take in that direction next
i agree
close soul groups and notebook by style
that's a cool function
that's a cool idea whether that's
something that
should be in um
uh you know a function versus something
in the cell menu is less clear to me
well you do want a programmatic way to
do it i think
i agree that i've needed that a bunch of
times i didn't know i was in the
function position
i mean the typical way you would do it
is close cell groups on
another um you know
uh on another notebook you know on a
notebook symbolically specified notebook
right um i would
think that would be the use case for for
the function
version
as opposed to a cell menu
well i see this is interesting that does
it on the actual current
notebook
well there's no reason you can't do that
no i understand it's just a little weird
i mean it's okay you can do that and you
then you delete the cell
and then your notebook is just the way
it should be
um
hmm
do we have anybody from the front-end
team here
no i'm i'm just i'm just suspecting
you know
so this leaves open so in principle i
could give this a list
i could say section and subsection then
it will close up those two levels
now this is actually a useful function
um well i like this function i'm not
completely certain this is the right
packaging of it
um question for lou maybe and john i
think so
yeah i think so but i like it it's a
good idea
that one seems iffy i'm not sure why we
care about this one
as a built-in
all right common what what's the
difference between these
oh yeah they're opposites i guess i
don't really remember why we thought
those were
um worthwhile
i think those are very iffy
sort the characters in a string
yeah i mean it's amusing i don't think
it's
um
i mean to me that name is not clear
enough
as whether that means that the
string crushed into characters is this
joint
versus the string as given you know
um
like aabb
versus you know bb
a a disjoint as in can they be overlaid
on each other
i mean that's a string overlaps thing
right
yeah i mean they have an overlap
yeah you're saying what time maybe i'm
not sure what you're saying but no but i
mean if i if i change the second string
to a b
a a it doesn't have an overlap oh it has
another lap at the beginning
yeah okay fine if you got one character
in common you have some kind of overlap
right
one character at the end in common oh oh
i see you can place
yeah i see what you mean um
yeah i don't think that i don't think
this is a big thing okay
okay sluggify
yeah i i tend to think these are quite
useful
i mean they're a little bit wild and
woolly but i think there's a
hmm having a curated collection of these
things seems useful to me
it's something you want to do um
i mean it's even a um
it's not just url friendly it's also
filename friendly and things like this
i think we discussed things like this
before maybe there's a more general name
than sluggify
and we can have a something string name
right i don't think this is a good idea
to make it part of decapitalize
yeah this is something that can have
multiple options with like
ignore diacritics and things like that
to control right this is a different
thing
look this is a convention for
you know how to deal with spaces in a
name
i don't know the sluggify is really the
the i don't know where that comes from
the word slug
i think it probably comes from from
old-fashioned lead tight printing or
something
but
but it will also change capitalization
and perhaps remove diacritics
things that could be potentially
confusing i would expect it to do all
that
right but i think it should be more than
just decapitalized because that's a
completely different
well but when you oh i see that you're
doing this oh wait a minute
are you saying
i just think it's really obscure to have
decapitalized be the thing that
basically makes it url friendly
right the capitalized is just one part
of it
and not the difference between
decapitalize and to lower case
um because decapitalize only
has various options for decapitalizing
first words and let me look okay
the first character has been made
lowercase that's it okay
yeah but this function cannot be
responsible for introducing
hyphens or right
i mean i would say this is more like
some kind of encode string or something
i don't know what's the general word for
sluggify but i think we should have such
a function i see
i i believe in having this function i
just i'm not sure about its name
slugofy seems to be the name these days
then maybe we should just call it
sluggify yeah without the string
decapitalized sluggify
all right let's study the possibility of
sluggify
a slug is a unique string normalized
version of title
often used as part of the url and
sluggify is the
process to make it fun
string wrap
no i don't think we need this in the
modern world i mean i don't think we
need that as a built-in thing
um
okay i don't know i mean maybe i'm wrong
but
it certainly is something that's useful
i will
how would you do it the question is
whether to
do a more serious kind of wrapping than
just
chop it with a string partition
i'm thinking just trying to do
word-based strapping and things
oh it is
hmm
that's more useful i agree that's more
useful
i wonder how it works we are doing now
similar things not for full texts like
here for
geo labels which we have countries with
very long names so we have to wrap them
things like that depending on our
maximum length
yes okay fair enough
maybe this is a useful thing to have i
mean i agree that i can see it
programmatically being used in labels
for example
all right let's look at this i mean and
the question here i think will be
is you know what does the 40 really mean
it's probably like the page width option
okay i agree this is useful because
again
yeah you might very well want to use it
in in things like labels
okay this from camel case i had
yeah i mean
um
i don't know whether that's part of this
i don't think decapitalizes the right
place but
i had thought um
this is not as trivial a function as it
appears
i don't think i'm trying to think here
um
yeah because because you really don't
want it to capitalize those words
you really want it to appropriately
lower case those words
so you're taking something which is like
a function name or a name of a canonical
you know
a standard name of an entity and you are
de-cameling it
uh in a way where it ends up with an
actual
sort of human readable thing at the end
those i think there's a more difficult
problem we've talked about using
you know all kinds of fancy machine
learning things for this i don't think
it's you know i don't think it's a
straightforward structural
thing that makes sense wait
isn't it just um string splitting
and then re-merging with spaces
no because the problem is if you want to
lower case the things you have to know
what to lower case
look the most common case is something
like
um you know take an entity name
some name of a chemical or something
it's got a bunch of camel casing in it
many of those words should be should be
lowercased
that's the useful instance of this
there is an easy way to obtain string
split
to split up capitals
not easy i mean there's ways to do it
but i don't think it's particularly easy
um
hmm okay well i'm not sure what to do
with this one i think this one is more
complicated than it appears
i think it's a useful function but i
think it's more complicated than appears
i don't know if this can be done
reliably enough i think that something
like this a general version of this
would be useful i mean part of speech
queue that's what i was
actually advocating for in the meeting
fine well and and then i mean already
part of speech
is a function right
i guess this is based on that
right so i mean this would answer the
question
could this be a such and such right
not sure how incredibly useful it is
because
in a sense you know text cases
look it's probably a harmless thing to
have i mean obviously it would have to
have a language option etc etc etc
you know part of speech cue fish
noun language arrow
english in this case
it's reasonable it's a reasonable thing
to have as part of our our suite of
linguistics capabilities who works on
that stuff
that'd be me nick okay
okay key replace replace keys in an
association
oh boy
well these are actually interesting
place keys in an association so this is
saying
i can't believe we don't have another
way to do that
i mean we've got key sort and all those
kinds of things
i would have expected key replace though
to be replaced
i see key sort sorts on the keys
right right
right i do agree that key replace does
seem to be a reasonable thing that seems
missing
now what happens if key replace maps
two keys to the same thing what happens
to the you know to the association
because the association has to have
unique keys right or to an existing key
i would expect
whatever comes last wins
i think this is kind of wacky i think it
should just apply to a particular
association sitting in front of its nose
well it defaults
to everything well maybe that's right
because you want to do it on a data set
for example
ah yeah but
as far as i remember usually key
functions and
association functions are
one-dimensional
i thought so
but i mean okay so the question is if if
it is a
if it's a you know contractive mapping
so to speak and key replace replace
you know maps two keys onto the same
thing
[Music]
you know arguably there should be some
combiner function in here
that determines what to do i think it's
what should happen
just like we have a combiner function
what are some other cases of this
um where you can map multiple
things onto the same key
um
what's it called that that um
oh my gosh what is that operation called
the one where the only you take um
uh okay concatenation
no no no no no no no standard database
operation
um
oh yeah join across
or merge
both of those have um
have the notion of um what to do
combining it you know what to do when
you combine identical keys
that's what seems to me key replace has
to have but that's you know
that seems like a
a reasonable thing map at key
why isn't that just map at
with a symbolic part number why don't we
generalize map
to work on associations
but but but
what's wrong with that idea nothing's
wrong with that
i don't other than
map at works on places
right exactly and we don't
you know places are implicit other than
in
associations so associations would be an
outlier in terms of
it's the behavior is uniform for
everything but then there's some
specialized stuff
well no it's it's like i see what you're
saying i see what you're saying you're
saying there's a part number here
i could just say part one there
and that would do that yeah that's an
ambiguity if you say hey
and you expect it to operate on the a
rather than its
value
right fair point fairpoint that's an
argument for map at key
i think that's a that is a somewhat
useful function perhaps oh yeah
perhaps it's more like a keymap
yeah no because keymap at would
would do the operation on the key
and he said that's what this is isn't
that what we
what it's doing map at key no
no no what this is doing is it's saying
take what i'm imagining is
[Music]
right it's it's saying take this
association
and um
oh boy that's even more exotic
wow that's exotic
we don't have that for map at
oh this is not yeah this is not what i
thought
okay so what i'm imagining this does is
that map at key
what it does appears to be like your
extension to map
at proposed yeah right
of a goes to
a goes to f one yeah yeah it goes to two
well this already works by saying key of
a
in map oh well then then we've solved
the problem
okay then we don't need this okay
yeah i i i thought this was a key oh it
says
yeah oh never mind but it does the the
function repository version does
multiple
uh cases and so on by the way we should
probably record these comments
somehow in the function repository pages
um not easy
what do you mean if you're talking about
putting them in the documentation
well i'm thinking that we might want a
design discussion so that we don't
in other you know so first of all so
people who are looking at these don't
say
oh what's the relationship to this thing
oh why isn't it the same etc etc
and also so we don't in two years come
back and look at these again
and say you know and have to repeat our
conversation
some of this probably shows up under
properties and relations
when the authors or reviewers are savvy
enough to realize
that there's a need for that yes
well i still think it will be useful to
record somewhere
that we've had the discussion
and concluded that we yeah
no devin's kind of doing that isn't he
perhaps so i mean just but but but we
need a way to connect these things to
the
function repository information
maybe we should just link the
appropriate section of the live stream
to the function repository page
yeah and like i've been well at least
starting last time i've been keeping
track of all the
time stamps okay compressed with
definitions
well that's an interesting idea but i
don't know you know
i don't know the relationship between
compress and i can eyes and all those
kinds of things nowadays
right
i think both just work at the expression
level
they do but i mean one could imagine and
i can eyes with same definitions
yeah yeah well that's sort of what is
being proposed here
only restricted to compress
right well basically a safe definitions
option to compress
yes
i mean that's what the note is is
getting at
okay but i mean i think also the other
thing to think about there
is um a safe definitions option to
iconize which i think would be super
useful actually
i also don't know the again the relation
between i can eyes and compress
i think one uses the other
okay i think fine
then what i recommend is a is a
um i can eyes
i can eyes with same definitions i'd
never thought of it before but it's a
good idea
i would not omit compress from that
no no no no no compressed should also be
that yeah
i mean i'm i'm asking i'm one thing i'm
wondering about
is what actually is the result from a
compressed with safe definitions is it
with
i am not sure
okay
we have some comments on the live stream
ultra is asking will there ever be a
statically typed
version of mathematica design from the
ground up i think the answer to that is
no but the the for the work that we're
doing on the compiler there absolutely
is a way of doing type specifications
using the typed wrapper
and you learn from that what an
extremely bad idea
it would be to try to impose static
typing on the flexibility of language
that we have
it's it's actually um i mean it's
interesting what you can do with static
typing
and um yes the things that
that you get can be compiled blindingly
fast
but there's a just there's an
unbelievable number of weird
things that you know where basically the
the way you learn that it's a bad idea
is by seeing how complicated the type
expressions get
for even fairly simple things
um uh
my stack is asking about ui ux
improvements
um yes but not for this meeting that's a
that's a different topic
different set of completely different
set of people um
i thought we had a dark mode do we not
have a dark mode
ui i'm sure we do because i've seen
people using it
i don't know wrong people here to
probably discuss that
that actually could be i mean we do have
one or two of those in the
function repository whether they've come
up for
promoting i don't know okay fair enough
okay
i i recommend by the way people who want
to think about types think about the
null list
and consider its type
and then start thinking about what yeah
all the things you do with something
like that
and or are where functions
oh yes it's another joy
anyway they have some very interesting
new ideas by the way about how to
uh kind of uh turbocharge the compiler
and the compiler effort um using
essentially combinations of compiler
ideas and ux ideas
anyway coming to an another meeting soon
um reminds me you should perhaps be in
that meeting jose there's a sort of
compiler summit meeting coming up
um
uh maybe um
uh devin could could make sure to take
that note okay
as well okay um
copy definitions
interesting and weird it's the sort of
thing though that we
i think already do in um
exposing functions that um
say lived in the uh you know will from
alpha
or in some arg context
that sort of thing what do you mean copy
definitions if you say
the fibonacci function and it has some
memorization and so on
and what does it mean to copy
definitions
say copy after g okay you're presumably
replacing the f's that appeared
on the right hand side as well as the
f's that appeared on the left hand side
you might be copying the memorization
yeah
and i don't remember offhand if it does
although i suspect it does
but i think the more the use case is to
um
catch not just down values but
but all other well i know but even
catching down values is non-trivial for
the reason i just mentioned
yeah and it's not completely obvious to
me i mean you have to be quite careful
about scoping with those things
um quite careful quite quite careful i
can imagine all kinds of weird things
that could happen
um
i mean i think this is sort of an
interesting idea but i'm not sure i mean
honestly the number of times i have
missed having this function
over the years is not large so
it has been very useful for people
um if i'm not mistaken for people who
are writing
uh you know exposing internal
functionality in the function repo
which is internal tool smithing
why is it useful for that
um it's a clean way of
uh slurping up definitions from um
uh some you know whatever internal
hidden private
context to um into the function
repository as a
as a but then you statically need to
have that in the source notebook so i
don't understand what good it does you
that's something i'm saying so at
runtime look
if i've got a function f and i want it
to be equal to a function g
or a function g i want to be equal to f
and um you know one way i can do that is
just say g
equals f that every time i see g it's
turned into f
right now the only way that that will
not be the right thing
is if f and g have separate lives with
different memorization
for example why don't you check out the
you know details and options here and
maybe the scope see if there's
ah i see okay
call me definitions
what this might be ancient
i don't understand this why don't we ask
rick what the story of this is
fair enough this looks weird
symbol dependencies
that's sort of interesting i mean that's
a low-level factorization
of safe definitions in some sense
that seems useful to me it seems like
the kind of thing where
um
[Music]
could even return graphs of dependencies
it could be
interesting
and what would that look like
oh i see what you're saying you say
every node is a symbol
and this is saying this symbol depends
on this this this and this
right that would be interesting that
will be useful to people
and then the vertex list is all
symbols well i mean this goes along with
tools that we want to do for the call
graph the call graph is different from
the dependency graph
right the call graph is a execution
computation story and this dependency
graph is a
pure you know essentially
what has a value that depends on the
value of what
i like the idea of trying to make a
dependency graph symbol dependency graph
maybe we can start with that as a
function repository item
maybe somebody can suggest that to rick
make sense
yeah okay
uh full symbol name we should probably
be inviting him to this meeting by the
way
because he has so many function
repository entries not just that but
um his uh background knowledge and mine
are more or less complementary
fair enough though that sounds like a
good idea when we're going to discuss
function repository promotion stuff
right that's what i meant
not in general but for that
oh boy
interesting i mean i i hope that's not
the best factoring of this
seems like it should be a an option to
symbol name
nick is information doing this already
full symbol name like with the context
yes i always present him somewhere the
symbol with its full context
yeah it's not the the primary header but
the fully qualified name that's getting
included
or you're suggesting that it's a case of
information or something
yeah something that could be extracted
from information yeah there's a full
name parameter
that so if you say information of f
quotes full name yep it'll give system
or i guess in this case global backtick
f
well that seems useful it should also be
then it should be linked from the symbol
name page here
seems like that's a pretty decent
solution to this
what the heck is this oh that's
interesting
that does seem like a decent idea to be
able to have a context setting for two
string
because that's not something we
currently have and i mean i have no idea
what context
stuff it puts in that making sense
like what context does two-string
imaginative stringifying
in
it's got number marks but it doesn't
have context
right and it probably should have
you mean so that the symbols in the
string are fully qualified
that's correct are qualified for the
appropriate context for what it says
you know in other words if you want to
locally set a context
in which the string will in which the
expression will be interpreted
okay this would also be an option i
would think for the export functions
that go to strings
uh you know sorry that take expressions
and just write out wolfram language
source code basically
i'm surprised we haven't run to this
issue before
am i making sense i'm still confused so
the symbols
will gain their own current context
it will qualify the thing if you think
you're writing out two string for a
certain current context
then then symbols in that then
current context will not get context
will not be qualified
but if you say i want two string to
write out assuming that i
know that no contexts are on the context
path and so on
then i mean you know it could have a
context path option effectively
right and that would determine whether
it will write out whether it will think
of itself
i have no idea how you would do that
right now how how it would write itself
out
with appropriate context names
perhaps by blocking context paths well
yes
but that seems like a pretty hacky way
to do it and i'm not even sure you can
achieve everything that way
anyway that's my suggestion is that we
look at the um
context path options for things that
write expressions to strings
i don't even know how the wxf stuff
works with that how does that work
does it maintain the context information
i don't know
okay is wxf distinct from what we do for
mx files from dump save
most definitely
all yes we should play rap soon here but
but let's just try and do a few others
inline that seems like a horrifying
concept
what the heck does this even mean
what ask wreck
i i just joined but um the basic idea of
that it's the
something i do often is you have with
like x equals x
just to insert the value of something
into a held expression
and this basically is just the sure i
see that's interesting
okay hold on i think about that
i agree that the with x equals x is
totally horrifying
but what is the way really to do that
how how does
let's see you've got a you've got an
expression in which
x is held and
one thing you could do would be to say
slash dot x arrow whatever
if i'm not mistaken yeah
but you want to do that
executionally so to speak rather than
yeah i'm not completely what is okay
explain to me that the factoring of with
okay so this is saying so that's the
value of x
so this is the equivalent inline of x
comma x square
is equivalent of with x equals x comma x
bar
right so in other words it's releasing
basically just the x's inside x bar
yeah essentially it's basically in this
case it's using the own values of x as
the replacement rules
for like replace all
i understand i understand but basically
what it's doing is it's saying
um uh
you know unhold wherever i had this
um you know it's basically saying
unhold a specific
you know a specific symbol
in an expression uh yeah
that actually is probably a better name
well i'm not sure that's the right way
to do it i mean i i'm i mean
that's a concept though um
although it doesn't fully evaluate it
so it's it so it does does it in place
does it echo what's that that first
example it doesn't echo
um so it just does one replacement like
into the own values of x but doesn't
doesn't really unhold it right look i
think getting rid of the with x
equals x uh idiom would be a really good
thing i'm not sure if this is
i mean okay let's put that on the agenda
to discuss that
okay i'm not sure this is the complete
solution but let's put that on the
agenda
okay devon yep i got it
okay what is this
why is this not
boy what is this
what's the difference between this and
local um
and uh um session evaluate
so this will evaluate something on a
fresh kernel that has no definitions no
you haven't loaded any packages or
whatever like it's
it's pretty useful for testing things it
is useful that is a good idea
and i figured since we have cloud submit
and cloud evaluate
we have local submit but no local
evaluation it seemed to make sense
that does make sense that does make
sense
it's a good idea so it will spawn a
separate process and just
do the evaluation and return the result
yeah so it'll
it'll start a new kernel and just
evaluate that thing and then
that kernel quits and gives you the
result sounds useful to me
i think we should yeah that's a good
idea
is there any way of controlling which
kernel do you want
so if i have several versions and i want
to control with which one
i want the valuation that probably
should be done in the same way that we
deal with external evaluate
i mean what is the difference between
this oh i see external evaluate takes a
string
i mean there's some relationship between
this and what
jose is saying and the whole kernel
connection manager thing
and the wstp server because
this local evaluate could be oh do this
but make sure it's on a different
core or whatever else i mean this is
this local evaluate
okay the basic point is you know you're
allowed to do it because it's on your
current machine
in some sense it's not like a remote
evaluate where you have to go and
authenticate on another machine and so
on
making sense right yeah
and what does this actually do how does
it actually call the program internally
rick
it it basically just throws some extra
wrapping onto local submit so it it does
use local submit and it waits for the
the result it uses the task finished
handler to
to return that i see
well let's let's get this in a meeting
that involves roman
and so on who did local submit who's
whose
thing is that was that constantly
maybe let's get this in a meeting with
those guys
but it looks like a good thing
fail on message that's the same thing as
confirmed quiet
yeah same idea says
i think one of the things we're talking
about is maybe it'd
be nice to have an option to something
like confirm or confirm
match to also check for messages so you
know but confirm
quiet does check for messages
confirmed does fail if if there's a
message
so you'd be saying confirm quiet of
confirm match
whatever so you're saying a messages
option
to confirm match yeah i'm trying to
remember
what that seems unnecessary i mean i
think you can just say confirm quiet of
confirmed match
yeah this this one might just be
considered obsolete
okay if that's the case we should make
sure it references
um uh right confirm
yeah it doesn't reference confirmed
quiet and it needs to okay i can
update that one to mention okay
once unless failed
well that's interesting
that's interesting that's a confirm once
type thing
once yeah if i were naming it now i
probably would have put
confirm somewhere in the name anyway so
let's think about how that works i mean
if you say once of confirm actually
that's an interesting way to do it i
mean to just have the the idiom of of
once of confirm
and then it just doesn't see what i'm
saying i think once of confirm would
just do the right thing
yeah if you have the enclosed outside of
the once it would work
right and close once confirm
seems like a good idea i mean that seems
like just an idiom that we should
promote
and once and then confirm i hadn't
thought of it but it's a good idea
i don't think it needs its own function
i think there are enough different
things that you want to do if it fails
and so on that you really don't want to
have a separate function for that
i mean there's nothing wrong with them
in the function repository but i think i
think that's a
um readable form
what the heck is this
what is the point here it's a pretty
printer
of sorts of layout you know how it does
the layout i think
it's like input form but it it adds
spacing and
yeah line breaks well that's interesting
so what's the relationship between input
form and brenton's recent
kind of i mean why do why doesn't input
form get the same capabilities as
brenton's code formatter
because it's ancient and nobody
really wants to dive into that code base
right but the fact is that whatever
brenton's code formatter is in
is doing could intercept the string
being generated by input form
and i just haven't thought of this i
mean input form should get
some
uh you know it's even possible that
input form by default
should use a code formatter
well maybe it does it just uses a very
unairy code formatter right
i think that's a correct statement
although it does insert spaces
before and after uh in fix operators for
example
or at least some of them okay okay
and then i mean i think the bigger
question is
what is the relationship between input
form and code formatting
i i think it's pretty much as you both
have said
one is sort of a more primitive version
of the other
all right but then i yeah
the you know input form is is 34 years
old
um i
had not thought of this but i think we
should raise that in the next code
assistance discussion
okay
and i don't know what heuristics rick is
using here
for readable form and how they relate to
what brenton is doing
do you know uh
this is stuff i wrote a long long long
time ago
and i barely remember what it does
okay i mean one one possibility is just
to bring it to brenton's
attention yeah if he has comments like
oh
i can do this better now or oh this is
some ideas i need to
yes myself or whatever i agree
makes sense to me because we've got all
these kinds of issues yeah
yes these are these are interesting he
seems to be a good person to comment at
least
yeah right but this is an interesting
option that's an interesting option
he's got that option
that's an interesting one he doesn't
have so yeah i think that's a good place
for this
contains q i thought we already had a
contains queue
not really we have the contains family
but in the end we never
did this would this fit in there this
infinite depth contains or not
um
it seems like it's a
length of cases uh with negative one
um you know greater than zero
no i i think this is not for the q right
not what not freaky that's true it is
just a
pattern thing so yeah not freak you look
i find it
super hard i have to say even after all
these years
every time i use free q and member queue
i have to look up their argument order
yeah well the main thing is that
member q is looking at first level well
free q is looking at all levels
indeed and and that's why there is the
need for this contain skew which would
look at all levels
so it's a remember trigger but it's
useful yeah it is useful if it
if people can really understand what's
going on
well it's going to be a bit confusing
with respect to member queue
i agree okay let's put this
on our list to discuss in another ild
meeting
the you know free q member queue
question mark contains q
just the fact that it's so hard to
remember
these argument orders and perhaps that's
a sign of bad naming
yeah but we're not going to change those
argument orders obviously we're not so
contains q i will say absolutely must
have the same ordering as free queue
absolutely absolutely so there's really
not a whole lot to discuss here
we we're we're constrained
well i understand but the question is do
we want it and is the name sensible
okay okay fair enough
okay
eliminate lists why isn't that oh i see
that that's basically the
equivalent this select version of delete
cases
this discard thing yes
right exactly it's a great function
repository entry
deselect you could call it
well not really
it doesn't seem critical i mean
something though that people have asked
for for a very long time
and and for exactly that reason you've
got cases and delete cases you have
select
and what case
what we don't business
no i understand well okay what would it
be
delete select that's why i was saying
deselect
but yeah but it would make more sense to
call it delete select
it might
have people asked for this um
once upon a time teo gray did uh
it's something i have on rare occasion
wanted but it has come up
it's a little bit of a weird name look i
agree
that saying
you know delete everything that isn't a
number
but you know you can also select
everything that is a number
i mean it's a question of putting not in
front of the predicate
useful to like delete failure queue
expressions
wait a minute so but that's well there's
also delete missing and so on
which goes with this
which is in a sense a version of delete
select
sorry what were you saying rick i mean
there isn't a delete failure yet is
there
no i don't think so but like
that's uh an idiom that i found really
useful
is select not failure queue a lot
yes i agree
what about maybe it's a stretch but we
have select what about remove
we've already got remove it means
something completely different
right it's this right
yes we do yes
um
okay
uh let's see
dumb stick on the live stream is asking
isn't contains q kmp what is kmp
sub string such this isn't strings this
is expressions
there's a completely different string
contains q is a completely different
function
and that indeed just does substrings
well i think this this question of a
delete failures
is sort of interesting
and probably should be should be looked
at because i can imagine something that
somehow matt
you know connects with confirm
like for example is there a way
of saying i have this list and
everything
i mean i suppose i could say something
like
um in my list yeah i don't know how to
do that i mean
in other words given the list anything
that did something funky generate a
message or otherwise
you know uh
do you get what i'm saying it's it's
sort of a confirmed cases or something
given a list um
you know
no that's not right it's not right it's
not right it's not right that's not
right
but you know it's like given a list i
want to keep only those elements where
nothing funky happened
right so something that happens with
delete missing is that typically when
you want to delete a missing you also
are worried about things
around so these additional arguments to
delete mission
are important and not diffic not easy to
use i would say
sometimes i have to say i think that the
name discard really does have the right
connotation
possibly yes
oh boy yeah that's
not friendly i mean possibly there there
should be some named arguments
right so this is the sort of thing in
which for example imagine that
during a geo operation a latitude came
up as
dollar failed how do you say i want the
whole the opposition removed
i understand that's a good topic let's
talk about that
okay it sort of confirm meets
or something meets you know
confirm is an execution time story this
wants to be an expression structure
version of confirm
right and i i think that's the
that makes sense that analogy i think so
how should that work ask christopher he
might have an idea about this
okay all right we should really wrap
up here um okay but i think this is a
very useful process
and um let's go on next time i think
okay uh okay great thanks a lot guys
thanks to folks on the live stream see
you another